all right we like to make it interesting
when we ask for questions on twitter we
like to get your attention and i like to
use office gifts because the office
exclusively streams on peacock there's
kevin with the
stick flip and the smash on the symbol
and yes he was indeed as rmd 1064 points
out
famously in a police cover band
scrantonicity and also scrantonicity too
not to be confused with scrantonicity so
let's answer some questions from today's
kevin malone inspired mailbag
this one first though comes from the
peter king mailbag
you get email questions in response to
your football morning in america column
fmia reader chris de la tour why are you
pooh-poohing the chiefs run by playing
the what if game peter why are you doing
that
hey the bottom line is i wrote my column
the other day i'm a little i'm
a little bit rethinking you know the
kansas city chiefs as
the greatest team of this era i mean
they
in consecutive super bowls you know they
have
scored 10 points in the first 50 minutes
of last year's super bowl and this year
in
60 minutes they scored nine points one
touchdown in those 110 minutes in
16 drives now hey look
they did come back obviously to their
credit and all to their credit and score
21 points in the last
whatever six six and a half minutes in
the super bowl against san francisco
great for them but i i mean mike
you know you've got to admit and uh and
to
my letter writer i appreciate you
writing but you've got to admit
that those were not good offensive
performances overall in either
game and so that's why i'm questioning
the chiefs i think
andy reid believe me is not is not
sort of andy reid doesn't go i'm poo
pooing that that
that that doesn't mean anything andy
reid notices that
and he's also saying hey by the way we
have to struggle to beat the four and 12
falcons at home
and we should have had to go to overtime
to do it but their kicker
missed a 37-yard kick or whatever it was
but
but i just think there's some things
that it seems to me that people are
catching up to
that kansas city does offensively yeah
and when they don't do
things like add extra blockers to help
with the five guys who are struggling to
stop the front four of the buccaneers
that makes it even worse devin white
made that point earlier this week on fs1
that they can't say oh
our top two tackles were injured when
they did nothing to help the two tackles
that took their place and 92 percent of
the time had only five blockers
to help patrick mahomes who ultimately
ran 497 yards for his life behind the
line of scrimmage in the game
mike dowell 188-76340 always want to get
the handle
accurate has eric the enemy's stock
fallen after the chief's below par
offensive performance in the super bowl
and has he been overtaken
by both byron leftwich and todd bowles
the offensive and defensive coordinators
respectively of the buccaneers
in terms of future head coaching hires
peter your thoughts
i'll give my thoughts and i'd really
like to hear yours on this as well mike
but
i think there's two things you have to
consider here
number one you know eric the enemy
over the last three years has been
a quote hot candidate end quote and he
hasn't gotten a job
it isn't only all the teams that have
interviewed him
okay it is all the teams that have
considered him and chose
to not interview okay and you have to
look at that
you have to say look if i'm the nfl
right now mike
i am basically saying hey look we have
done
everything in our power to help eric the
enemy and
right now it might be incumbent on us to
start to look at a new crop
you know especially of the younger
coaches like
byron leftwich younger minority coaches
and i don't know that they're going to
do that but as i look at it
you know do you want to keep pounding
your head against the wall i think eric
b
enemy is being done wrong we've talked
about that ad infinitum
but i do think there comes a point where
you have to ask yourself
are we going to head into this and try
to force him into a job
again in 2021 or
are we going to start to look at new
guys byron left which is a fascinating
candidate he got zero interviews in this
latest cycle
but as bruce arians talks more and more
about what he really does he runs that
offense he calls the plays
aryans said on colin coward's show
yesterday
that one of the reasons he keeps going
is he doesn't want to have to call the
plays and if leftwitch had gone
aryans may have considered retiring and
it sets up an intriguing situation for
this year because if leftwich starts
getting
interviews and there's a thought he's
going to get offers
maybe that's when aryans walks away so
the buccaneers can keep leftwich and
they don't lose both guys and if i'm tom
brady
and i'm thinking about extending my
contract beyond 2021
i want to be damn sure i'm going to have
aryans or leftwich beyond 2021 if i
commit to staying past this season peter
yeah and let me just say one other thing
about this mike for anybody who would
say
that uh that byron leftwich is basically
you know writing bruce aryan's coattails
i had an interesting conversation a
couple of right after the game really a
couple days after the game with clyde
christensen the quarterback coach
who you know has been around forever
coach manning you know has coached
everybody
and he he called byron leftwich a savant
and we discussed one play in particular
in this game mike the first touchdown
pass to rob gronkowski
rob gronkowski has never run
that route and caught a pass in his
career
you know if he ever comes into motion
you know what he does
very often on that play he seals the
end on that side so you see frank clark
right when he is coming into motion
frank clark is girding
you know for gronk to hit him you know
and yet gronk runs right past him
catches the pass
goes in and gronk goes to the sidelines
and says that's unbelievable i've never
done that before
easiest catch of my life easiest he's
untouched
on it untouched totally and at that
at that time clyde christensen said
that was the one play that was the one
play
that that byron left which could not
wait to call in this game because he
said
nobody will be expecting this at all and
so he was
he was he was just like very he was
yearning
all through the pre-game and and early
in that game to call that play
when they got in position they did it so
hey look
leftwitch is a real smart guy i think
things will change for him next year
and that's a great point i mean to the
extent that he's able to acquire that
knowledge process and have a creative
way to twist it know when to do it
that adds to the notion that he is ready
to run a team of his own
a question from an fmia reader this is a
gentleman named aaron peter
you wrote that urban meyer needs someone
to be his conscience
why are you letting him off the hook how
about he finds
his own conscience what say you
i think it's a very good point i i would
agree that urban meyer
needs uh to think about
things like hiring the iowa strength
coach when
he has a a history of of racially based
comments
but i think this mike i think urban
meyer learns
something in that particular situation
he learned that just because
jacksonville is not a big town or
it's not philly or new york or chicago
or whatever
it's also not iowa city
and and i think he also learned that
you know i can't get away with hiring
these sketchy guys
when i come to the nfl my only point
about him
needing somebody wouldn't you think
that someone in that organization would
have said
uh coach um
you can't hire chris doyle okay you
can't do that
and even if somebody did if somebody did
he ran roughshod over him and hired him
anyway
but my feeling is nobody said that to
him
and i think that's why i think he needs
someone to come in and to be able to say
hey coach you can't do that here
and i hope that they hire somebody like
that
yeah and i think either way it doesn't
matter because fundamentally you need to
have the self-awareness
you need to either be able to realize on
your own when you're about to step in
something that is brown and smelly or
you need to have somebody next to you
that will say
watch your step you need to be aware of
that and he's not or he would have had
someone in position
to tell him watch your step or he would
have seen it
himself he failed on both counts so i
think the the problem is
you have to have it starting within you
to
either recognize when the mistake is
going to be made or
have a sufficient breadth of
understanding of yourself that there's
someone there who feels empowered to say
probably not the best idea but this is
what happens when you give the keys
you give the keys to urban meyer and put
him completely in charge what does he do
he acts like he's completely in charge
but mike
you also have to realize that in 17
years
as a coach no one has ever
come after him for a hire before
and i look i have no idea who's been on
his staff
we do know that he had the situation
you know with the uh sexual abuse charge
at ohio state and all that we not with
him obviously
but we know that that situation was
totally messed up and i get it
but my point is that in 17 years as a
coach
he doesn't have and i'm not look i
i worked in ohio i went to college in
ohio i love ohio
but you can run roughshod over central
ohio you just
can you know if you're the king at ohio
state
and i just don't think you can do that
unless
maybe you're bill belichick and again i
don't think bill belichick would have
ever had
tried to hire chris doyle you know
because he would have known
it's like when bill belichick didn't go
get the presidential medal of freedom
he just knew you don't do that you know
you know
you know you're you're smart enough to
know that and i think that's one of the
things urban meyer is
is uh i think bill belichick had now i
think bill belichick had to be told no
uncertain terms
by someone whose name rhymes with craft
to not go do that that he really did
want to do it but that's where the
conscience comes
in robert that's the fail safe yeah
that's that's the fail-safe though peter
it's the dude with the handlebar
mustache in jacksonville
who has a power over urban mire that no
one has ever had over him before the
owner of an nfl franchise
and yeah urban meyer didn't avoid
stepping in that thing that was brown
and smelly
but he had shot khan who was able to
point out
you got something on your shoe and you
better go get the hose
and wash it off and i apologize
profusely for the
metaphor there but it was the only thing
i could think of one more real quick
gong show west do the new england
patriots have a viable plan for success
next season or have they already begun a
different kind of dynasty
a dynasty of obscurity
i mean bill belichick has a plan the
problem with their plan
is that they need so much
you know you not only need a quarterback
which is oh by the way you need a
quarterback i mean
that's only the most important guy on
any team in any sport
so you need to figure that out but the
other thing you need to do
is you need to make up for all the
horrendous decisions
he's made at tight end and wide receiver
you know over the last
six eight nine years i mean he has been
a disaster at
you know at picking skill players you
know and in the receiving game
and so that to me you you've got
this is not a one-year fix-it unless
kurt warner walks into the building and
he does what he did in 2000 or
whatever year that was 99 with the rams
i mean
this is a multi-year fix
and i think people love the new england
patriots you just got to be loyal fans
for now because you're not going to have
a good team this year
you're just not and you've got to be
willing
to put the time in and the effort uh
because tom brady is not writing to the
rescue
jr callow or kyo jr chao 13 which is
more likely i couldn't tell whether that
was an l or an i
j r chow 13 which is more likely the
texans are not listening to offers
or the offers aren't as good as expected
what do you think peter
i think the texans are going to draw a
hard line in the sand for a while
and say we're not trading them stop
calling us because
people are not going to stop calling
okay
they will know a week or so before the
draft
are they really going to listen or are
they not going to listen
you know so to me i think
you know the more i think about this and
i've thought about it a lot i'm writing
my column on it for monday
what's gonna happen to uh desean watson
mike you know this is this is going to
be
a gigantic moment in a lot of careers
what is done with desean watson
and peter my concern for the texans
not that i really care about the texas i
care about their fans i care that they
aren't suffering through years of
dysfunction and it seems like they may
be on track for that
the longer you wait to realize your best
move is to trade him
the worse the offers are going to get
because the teams that otherwise would
be at the table
are going to make other plans it gets
back to what you were suggesting with
chris ballard in the colts at some point
you're moving on
you're gonna make a plan at quarterback
that doesn't involve desean watson
because you've got opportunities that
you can't continue to wait for
an answer from the texans and i
it only takes a couple of teams to still
jump in and give the texans a good
return but i think their best return
is to go to deshawn watson now
get a list of teams that he would play
for because he has no trade clause he
has some control over this you get five
or seven teams
and you you you finagle an auction you
work the angles you
get them to bid against each other until
you you find
maximum return and the longer they wait
to do that the harder it's going to be
to get the most possible return so
what's going to be proven
that they're going to huff and they're
going to puff and eventually
desean watson is going to blow the house
down and get out of town anyway whether
it's because he sits out
for all or part of a year or whatever
but
i don't see the end game if they just
dig in
and say no no no you're a texan you're a
texan you're a texan
where does that ultimately get them
that's any better
than where they would be if they would
just accept reality now and move on that
that's the problem
i have with it you know i i don't have
the contract in front of me but
what is desean watson supposed to make
playing for houston
this year 20 not much 10 million 10
million
he got 10 he's got 10 million salary
next year it's 35 million
but this year it's 10. yeah well that's
a different story then because
if i were him that makes it eminently
more doable to sit out this year
obviously
but mike i i guess i guess i would ask
this question first
okay if you have a no trade clause
don't you as the player have to say
i'm waving my no trade clause for the
team to then go out and try to trade
them because because
just think about it suppose you say
i'll give you four teams and you can't
make a trade with any of those four
teams
they're offering you a lot less than
what you would consider market value
because honestly when you think about it
mike don't you think about that
you know if you want to go to four teams
wouldn't you maybe give the
houston texans four teams
and three of them don't want desean
watson
and only one of them does so that one
could offer
less so that when deshawn watson goes
there
they've got more chips to build up their
team
i i'm it's it's sort of asking for a
friend
i'll ask you well well and i think that
that makes sense and
and and let's face it even if he doesn't
have a no trade clause in his contract
as a practical matter
just like carson wentz carson wentz
didn't want to go to chicago
so chicago doesn't come to the table at
the end of the day it's going to be the
teams that are interested in desean
watson and the teams that he
has interest in and there should be more
than two or three
where those two mindsets intersect and
watson would go there
and the team would want him and and
however they come to that conclusion
they identify a universe of candidates
real candidates viable candidates
two three four five teams and then you
work them against each other
to get the best possible return that's
all i'm saying but the other side of
this too is if you're desean watson
do you want to go to a team that has
given up so much to get you that now
that team stinks
so you go from one team that stinks to
another team that stinks because they
gave up a herschel walker type of a
package
to bring you onto their roster
you know look there are a few teams
that need to be on that list and some of
them
are obvious like of course the new york
jets need to be on that list
but if they indeed
go to uh desean watson and say what
teams would you accept
if they do that there need to be some
teams
like for instance the san francisco
49ers
that to me is one of the mystique teams
in this whole deal i think kyle shanahan
would love to have desean watson
and you know mike let me just ask you
this question
and because we don't know the answer to
it
but how much do you think nick casario
was either
involved or had anything to do in the
scouting
or giving the nod to drafting jimmy
garoppolo
i when he was in new england i don't
know the answer
i don't think anybody right now knows
the answer
but that team to me is kind of sneaking
up on the outside
the only problem is i because my feeling
is and what i'm going to write on monday
i don't care what anybody says right now
the team that has the best chance
and to me is the most likely that you'd
make a trade with is the new york jets
because they've got the second pick in
this draft and if they have the second
pick in the draft and they trade sam
darnold
plus the second pick to houston
you know plus significantly more but if
you do that then houston is saying
look we love sam darnold anyway we'd
like to give him a shot anyway
so maybe then you start to rebuild your
franchise
that has been stripped barren of draft
picks and young prospects
because of all the draft mismanagement
they had there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports